[Musique]
mais il y en a eu plein de la vie si
tous qu'on est astucieux belle
c'est aussi le plus sérieux n'avait pas
joué il dit vouloir venir
xavier
à élaguer vision le flou mais qu'est ce
que ça a donné
je suis comme une crème renversée parce
que ça on dirait oui ou développe le jeu
aurait pas de remonter attends attends
j'ai essayé d'arranger ça ça va là
attention je me dis que j'ai dû glisser
c'est de la faute à ces tableaux de
neige oui ou alors tu auras attraper
froid dans la forêt en rentrant trop
tard hier soir ça je le savais qu'au
cours d'allemand mme à free ça marche
l'allemand oui grand-bassam europe 1 oui
dit il
ils m'ont dit d'aller vite a lancé dans
la neige oui parce que sa faune oui si
nous y sommes l'afrique alors didot puis
tu sais comment on fabrique nous avons
trois dessins oui nous avons trois
dessins et lille un admirable veut très
très bonne et ça oui
il vous le savez d'hervé le grand père
mais le grand bain il suffit qu ici tu
me laisses le dire par deux manières
dans l'ordre dans l'ordre delà de la
situation alors en principe la situation
commente rien mais si oui alors ici vite
alors c'est les sports d'hiver premiers
dessins d'esker de la neige
un hélicoptère bon je passe un autre des
jeux 2d de la neige c'est là un score
qui allait combler tout un bonhomme de
neige tient river plate où je tourne
olala d'esker de la neige et un bonhomme
de neige fatigué on reste confondu
c'est le terme d'ailleurs j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a qui est fondue
aussi alors tendu nourrit la solution
selon lui parlais à l'instant oui parce
que j'ai trouvé ton jardin
moi j'ai tout de suite été tué par le
bonhomme de neige regarde la lure qu'il
a ici tu vois c'est pas normal
alors je vais te dire une chose à mon
avis les choses se sont passées comme
suit premier dessin à mettre dans
l'ordre le bonhomme de neige
jeu est absolument intacts voilà oui tu
es d'accord deuxième dessin le bonhomme
de neige est à moitié fondue six bons et
enfin genre presque optimiser les
troisièmes dessin mais il est
complètement fondu à payer ces cristaux
rien je finis il est à fille c est toi
quand tu es passage c'est ça les voix
d'hommes jardry d'accord j'ai fait moi
je continue ma besogne oui la danse
c'est que je fais le plein comme un
smartphone que c'est que ça me rend pour
sauver les bagages arrivent encore de
côté sur les barques reprennent une
clairière madrague à lévis belle famille
petit chéri on appelle fabrice mais on
va l'appeler oui mais ça va mieux quoi
fabrice oui bref oui c'est à quel sujet
nous allons surprendre à bonne chose la
dernière fois on avait fait chuter je
n'ai pas gagné
voilà mais on va essayer encore un
d'accord bon figure toi aujourd'hui que
je fais partie d'une grande épreuve
cycliste sur route
ah bon c'est le point commun c'est le
oui n'a pas dit que c'était le point
commun si je dis que nous avons quelque
chose entre ans
entre nous tu vois en commun tous les
trois voilà d'accord je suis même la
plus grande épreuve cycliste je suis le
tour de france eh bien ça représente des
coureurs des suiveurs les départs au
petit matin les arrivées au sprint les
ascensions au sommet des cols les
descentes vertigineuses les chutes
quelques fois hélas et unac l'embarras
du choix
alors je veux tout de même te donne une
petite précision supplémentaire
oui mon rôle est surtout important dans
les étapes de montagne et je dois dire
que j'ai une tendresse toute
particulière pour les grimpeurs
ah oui je suis d'ailleurs pas sûr qu'ils
me rendent cette infection
je ne sais pas quand je suis autre chose
je suis un vêtement j'allais dire un
vêtement masculin mais à notre époque
les hommes et les femmes s'habillent de
la même façon ce n'est tous unisexe
alors disons qu'on peut me trouvais
aussi sur une femme pour être précise je
suis un gros chat un énorme changement
est bien là avec un col roulé qui monte
très haut
j'ai été tricotés avec de la grosse
laine et crois moi je tient chaud les
montagnards ne peuvent pas se passer de
moi
les marins non plus et n'oublions pas je
peux être très élégant d'ailleurs je
suis toujours élégant alors tout ce dont
je parle
oui je suis pas je suis pas à l'aise la
mine d'or je suis très embêté pour
l'instant je n'ai rien trouvé du tout ah
bon alors j'aimerais que tu me dises ce
que tu es parce que je pense qu'avec ton
histoire j'arriverais à m'en sortir mais
pour l'instant seront battus chez moi
mon histoire est très triste j'étais un
petit mouton jeu gambadait dans les
prairies au milieu de mes petits
camarades et je me retrouve chez le
boucher
oui et les ménagères viennent faire la
queue pour acheter
alors je les entends dire je voudrais un
beau chigot et hop on ne découpe en
morceaux alors une autre arrive dis je
je voudrais une belle épaules c'est pour
5 personnes et hop on pose sur une
balance et on annonce un kilo 300 ça ira
c'est dur c'est dur quand on a été ce
que j'ai été
enfin enfin il ya une chose qui me
console c'est que je suis marqué quand
même qualité supérieure heureusement
voilà c'est tout c'est un très beau
drame vécu en bas mais alors attends au
départ j'avais pensé à des lacets et
pensa à illumination soudaine
tu m'as dit le tour de france riz
montagneux oui tu m'as dit pour le vin
oui tu maghrib moutons plutôt oui les
mots que j'ai trouvée au décompte des
colloques des comptes dans un pull over
sea dx et par un meilleur
merci je n'ai pas quand tu fais du rip
un bail qui fait du tricot il ya des
codes île où il ya des côtes dans le
tour de france et il y à il ya il ya des
coupes de moutons oui oui mais aussi un
jeu musical qui favorise la tutelle
aucun j'ai hâte de te retrouver un
groupe
[Musique]
elle nous emmène alors c'est ça va être
à nous maintenant face à toi poussins
c'est à douala c'est à lui que je dis
moi tu as ton petit crayon
bon c'est formidable à l'art culinaire
ah bravo
j'y vais bon alors tu vas au tableau oui
alors bien rendre dès lors et au graff
aubin j'ai essayé quand même de s
impliquer résultats bon alors alors
c'est un mot en cette lettre ah oui je
commence par qui commence par un l comme
lucien comme lucien 1 2 3 4 5
le dernier sa dernière lettre est est la
dernière et la dernière 1 e
voilà alors j'attends tes petites
questions
une fleur non c'est pas une fleur un
animal ah oui oui je la trouvais
d'efforts
comment qui volent à nos il vole pas
alors ils veulent pas ils veulent pas du
court non ils courent porte ils
découvrent à nous un animal qui nage
non ils ne nagent pas
bourbon ils veulent pas inna sport
qu'est ce qu'il fait fi de leurs noms de
là et il glisse et y glisser dans les
jardins glisse dans les jardins et dim
et rend peut-être europe donne une
petite led supplémentaires non c'est pas
de refus la 13e par exemple la troisième
eh ben c'est un m même alors maintenant
tu devrais trouver un animal qui rentre
dans les jardins voilà est-ce qu'il a
des cornes
ah oui des fois huile en appui des
petites cordes tout petit
des petites cornes donc tu penses je
sens que tu penses à la limace toi
exactement exactement
il a trouvé il est formidable alors
lille as we libasse oui on l'écrit en
bon l'écrit l im à 2s eux
et voilà et wallin avant tout l im à 2
et wii est incapable comme iam la rue un
cas pas au regarde comme aucune image du
sexe vraiment ça ne va plus du tout du
tout du tout bon alors là il y est mais
voilà on écrit une menace alors qu'ils
sont tous en train de rire de toi tu
sais on peut pas on peut pas tout savoir
mais moi je serais pas fier à thalassa
est ce que tu sais ce que mangent les
limaces toi hein on espère bien un mange
des insectes oui j'ai très utile dans un
jardin parfaitement seulement elle mange
aussi autre chose
elle mange des petit verre et puis
figure toi qu elles se mangent entre l1
elles se mangent entre elles ces
pratiques là comme ça on n'a pas à
s'occuper de les détruire
et surtout elle adore les champignons y
compris les champignons vénéneux 1 et
s'accroît moi c'est c'est bien pratique
il savait pas tout ça ben non ça j'avoue
que tu m'apprends des tas de choses en
ce qui concerne les limaces aujourd'hui
bravo bravo pouces ou pas qu'est ce qui
te prend à tous grand concert commun
comme ça mon côté en battant va faire
tes notes à toi je vais t'aider jouer au
jeu latine à tarifer pas de ma joie la
lui fait pas de mal
on fait quoi les notes en avants fabrice
belle belle la vie c'est aussi la
musique tibétaine toi là tu va compléter
mes phrases avec les notes de la gamme
qui j'ai joué maintenant on joue ce jour
je les note je t'écoute
voilà alors aujourd'hui je voudrais te
parler de ta manière des tabliers
ah bon ce n'est pas que tu es pas
élégant mieux je voudrais te donner
quelques concerts poser quelques
questions d'abord pourquoi ne pour tout
jamais de veste
tu verrais très bien avec un veston bleu
marine agrémenté de jolis boutons de
boutons des boutons font pour ton venin
veste bleu marine
je dirai ensuite boutons dorés
c'est ça une veste à boutons dorés qui
n'en portent pas c'est drôle de temps en
temps mais pas dans la forêt bon oeil
dites moi est ce que ces derniers temps
tu n'es pas un peu gêné dans ses
vêtements est ce que ils ne sont pas un
peu trop étroit tu n'as pas légèrement
gros noms gros si ça jamais absolue et
un petit peu grossi si tu as un petit
bourrelet sur la droite on commence on
surveille tous étaient très mignons ils
t'ont col de chemise
lien ce col ouvert ça fait sportif ça
fait même dégagé mais tu sais ce que je
ferais si j'étais toi je porterai
d'école plus mais on faisait ça n'est
pas difficile obtenir il suffit de les
passer à
donc non il veut je remporte oui non oui
tiens regarde là mais dont est vrai
c'est que ce n'était pas tant parce que
c'est très avantageux
on peut beaucoup plus facilement
utiliser plus
enfin la même chemise autrement dit tu
pourras l'a utilisé pour réaliser les
alizés il inclura c'est très très dur où
là je vois pas d dont la koala laisser
dire que tu pourras l'âme l' elysée avec
mémé biden apporte une note mais tu sais
bien que d'autres on l'appelle aussi à
alors cette donne une [ __ ]
alors alors utiliser eu mais si tu
utilises plusieurs fois huttes
voilà c'est fait eh ben ça fait la halle
à l'arrêt wii u dont il usait qu'il est
marrant c'est fabrice ils ont beaucoup
tu mets jamais chapeau ça tirait très
bien tu sais puis enfin quand il ya du
soleil cela permet d'éviter des actions
b ça permet d'éviter les actions
chaoui le chapeau oui alors les
insolations bref au piémont cowboys
chéri d'ailleurs j'aimerais avoir avec
un grand chapeau où je suis avec toi tu
me laisses tomber encore une
je crois que dans l'état où tu es il
vaudrait mieux pratiquement te passer
très rapidement la kpu at-on force 4
l'acca qu'est ce que tu veux dire par là
et ben cherche un peu avec les notes
l'acca et bien tu veux dire michel
parfaitement calé camisole de force
allez rêver bien sûr à l'étude mais
mission avec un col bayard coûte non
suis gentil alors fischer lui c'est une
petite chance nous allons la chanter
les dates l'a dit déjà repas par konami
de talent
la vie vous diront qu'ils se plaignent
que la vie majeur s'est désisté et
rzeszow fait des choses mais comme juni
pas de mine war lèveront à faire
attention les cartes à mi parcours des
sens est dit les quatre amis sont de
retard il aime la vie
oui
[Musique]
alors
aujourd'hui vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]